can we say diamonds all eyes were on a
very blinged out Kate Middleton as she
attended the annual diplomatic reception
at Buckingham Palace on Wednesday from
her sparkly drop earrings to the
frosting around her neck the Duchess of
Cambridge once a regal vision but the
real showstopper was the levers not
tiara Kate used to complete her regal
look the crown was one of Princess
Diana's favorites and was given to Diana
as a wedding gift by Queen Elizabeth
Kate also wore the headpiece to last
year's diplomatic reception in addition
to sporting it at a state dinner in 2017
but the tiara isn't the only page that
37 year-old royal has taken out of her
late mother in-laws fashion book
Prince William popped the question to
Kate with his mother's sapphire
engagement ring that she rocks on the
daily he also gifted her Diana's
sapphire and diamond earrings which
she's since updated into a drop style in
2019 Kate Brock Diana's elegant diamond
and pearl earrings to the BAFTAs along
with the white Alexander McQueen gown
that was near identical to the
one-shoulder dress that Diana wore while
visiting Rio de Janeiro in 1991 in 2017
Kate debuted eyes frequently worn Thor
East and pearl bracelet during her royal
tour of Germany and here she is rocking
the late princesses for string pearl
choker while attending the 70th
anniversary party for the Queen and
Prince Philip of course Kate has also
paid homage to early mother-in-law
through fashion more times than we can
count
like they say imitation is the sincerest
form of flattery
[Music]